I thought we'd talk about a paper which
came out recently which has astronomers
scratching their head somewhat it's
called a population of red candidate
massive galaxies approximately 600
million years after the big bang nice
title and it's come out of the very
recent jwst observations
um so obviously it's kind of right at
The Cutting Edge of what's going on now
in studying Galaxy formation okay I
guess we need to go through what it is
that they've done
um before we can figure out why it's
weird or why it's sort of a little bit
problematic so I need to draw a picture
it's talking about the properties of
atoms and the fact that they have these
discrete energy levels there are only
certain energies that the electrons
around an atom can have and in the case
of hydrogen it's particularly simple
because you only got one electron to
worry about about what energy it's got
and so physicists draw these things
called energy level diagrams which are
just basically telling you what the
allowed energies the electron can have
and they kind of get closer and closer
together so you go up so you've got kind
of person you've got energy increasing
that way an electron has to be in one or
other of these energy states so if you
you've got a load of hydrogen wherever
it is but we're thinking about the
distant Universe it'll generally be in
this lowest energy State and so if
something were Illuminating this gas say
behind it and lighting it up the
electrons here could jump up if the
light had just the right energy from
there to there for example or to a
higher energy State and so on and what
that means is if we had a spectrum so if
we're measuring how bright the object
behind this gas is measured depending on
its wavelength if there were no guests
in the way then you'd just see kind of a
broad spectrum of light to do with how
hot that gas is and so on but because
some of the light is now being absorbed
by this material at these very
particular wavelengths then actually you
end up seeing these dips in the Spectrum
at these particular wavelengths and
there's a whole load of them that we can
have but you can see eventually you
reach a point where there are no more
energy states that basically is what
happens when the atom is being ionized
it will actually rip the electron right
out of the atom and now we can we're
free to pick any any energy you want up
here because there aren't particular
energies that are allowed you can have
any energy you want when you're kind of
ripping the electron out entirely and
what that does to the Spectrum is it
means that anything that's higher energy
than that jump there will tend to be
absorbed so energy translates when the
energy is higher than a particular value
that means the wavelength is less than a
particular value and so all the light on
that side gets absorbed so you end up
seeing kind of an edge here that you
lose all the light because any light
that had wavelengths this short will
have energy enough to rip the atom apart
so this is one of these things called a
break or an edge and transitions from
this lowest energy state are called
Lyman transitions brakes are really good
if you're an astronomer because the way
we figure out how far things are away is
by measuring the redshift measuring how
much the the light's been shifted to the
red because what happens is something
some distance away will emit light
towards us as it's traveling towards us
the universe has been expanding that
stretches out the light which makes it
redshifted so if something's further
away the light will have been traveling
for longer which means the light would
have been stretched out more which will
be means it'll be more rigid did so we
can translate the redshift directly into
how far away something is one of the
problems when you look at things in the
very different universe is that they're
very faint so measuring redshift is a
hard thing to do when things are very
faint you really can't get a nice
Spectrum like this but edges are easier
to measure because if you think about
what happens if instead of having a
spectrum if we just measured things in
kind of broad terms of say we've
measured where the red light was and
where the green light was and where the
blue light was and if you think about
taking a whole series of images at
different over different bands what
you'd see is you'd see the object here
but then when you started using bands
over here all the lights absorbs and so
the object will disappear
and so something where there is a strong
lineman break like this you'll have this
Effect called the alignment Dropout that
basically the object will just disappear
when you start measuring things that
blow away things than that the other
thing of course that's going on is that
the whole Spectrum gets redshifted as
you look to more and more distant
objects so in the rest frame when the
light was actually being absorbed this
feature is in the ultraviolet but when
you start looking at things in the more
and more distant universe that break
shifts to redder and redder wavelengths
which means that instead of being in the
ultraviolet it becomes into the optical
it actually moves into the near infrared
as well so I can show you some examples
from actually from this paper so this is
a whole series of images taken with jwst
at different wavelengths working their
way to Bluer and Bluer wavelengths and
you can see there's an object which is
stormingly bright and then quite quickly
just disappears it's vanished entirely
in these last two frames so each of
these images is working their way from
you know starting in the infrared and
working in their way towards the optical
part of the spectrum and so at some
point you reach a point where the light
becomes blue enough or less red enough
that actually the objects just disappear
this is a great way of identifying very
distant galaxies it has a couple of sort
of shortcomings the first shortcoming is
that you're essentially identifying
galaxies from the light that when it was
emitted was in the ultraviolet part of
the spectrum that ultraviolet part of
the spectrum is very high energy light
and in terms of what stars produce it
it's only very massive short-lived very
bright very hot stars and it doesn't
take many of them because they're so
bright that actually a relatively small
number of them will produce a load of
ultraviolet radiation which can then be
absorbed so you can then detect it in
this way so to infer from that the
global properties of a galaxy is kind of
a challenging thing to do because it's
really not telling you much about the
Galaxy
the second snag is that there are
various other breaks or other
wavelengths and if you're not careful
you'll identify something as a break
that something is nice and bright and it
suddenly gets very faint and identify
that as this lineman break but it could
be another break it could be something
else going on elsewhere in the Spectrum
and you'll end up attributing completely
the wrong redshift of this Galaxy and
end up with complete nonsense
so those are the two snags this paper
very neatly gets around it doing
something that we've only just been able
to start doing with the James Webb Space
Telescope and in particular everything
I've just told you about happening from
this lowest energy State can happen from
the next energy State up if there are a
load of atoms that are in this slightly
higher energy State then again there'll
be absorption at the various wavelengths
but eventually you'll reach the point
where the atom gets ripped to pieces the
electron gets ripped out entirely and so
you'll have exactly the same kind of
feature and that's called a Balmer break
because emission and absorption from
this second energy level is called balma
lines and so actually there's this kind
of balma break when atoms are being
ripped apart in some sense that will be
a killer thing in that if you you know
you've identified a Galaxy by this
lineman break but if you also see this
balma break in the Spectrum then you've
got two features and now you're pretty
sure actually I know what's going on
because these two features they're a
fixed wavelength apart and therefore
actually the fact that I've identified
both features really means I know what
I'm looking at that's the alignment
break that's the balma break and we
understand what's going on the reason
why we haven't been able to do that
before is that if you move the lineman
break all the way into the near infrared
which is kind of the most distant we've
been able to do in the past the bound
will break shift is all the way into the
mid infrared and we hadn't had a
telescope that could record data of the
quality needed to identify Brakes in the
mid infrared as well as in the near
infrared jwst can do both
and so they've actually been able to
identify what they call Double great
galaxies here's some of these plots are
showing what the intensity looks like so
this is how bright these galaxies are
and this is the wavelength that they're
looking at the red line is kind of a
model but the little points you can see
on here are the images they've actually
recorded how bright the Galaxy is at
these different wavelengths and these
two here are actually upper limits they
didn't detect the Galaxy at all there
and so here this is the lineman break
where you go from nothing at all to
suddenly being able to see the thing and
then there's a second step up this is
the balma break and it's a much smaller
feature but it's definitely there
there's a significant step up at that
point when you've got data like this
firstly you're really pretty confident
that you have identified a Galaxy at
those very great distances away because
you've nailed down these two break
features which are telling you what the
redshift really is but the second thing
is that now you're not just reliant on
the ultraviolet light because you've got
this data all the way so this was the
ultraviolet effects of the Galaxy but by
the time you're over here in the medium
infrared that was light that was emitted
in the optical part of the spectrum and
the optical part of the spectrum is
telling you not about those extreme
ultra bright Ultra massive stars it's
telling you about bog standard stars in
the galaxy and so by studying the
properties of these galaxies now looking
at these bog standard Stars you can
actually learn a lot about what the
properties of the Galaxy are like what
the mass of the Galaxy is for example
because if you've just got those Ultra
luminous very massive stars it doesn't
tell you much about what the total
contribution of to the mass of the
galaxies is just telling you there are a
few very massive stars whereas by the
time you're looking at this sort of
mid-infrared data which is telling you
about the optical part of the spectrum
that's telling you how many stars there
are like the sun and that's can fairly
directly translate into how massive
these objects actually are so the
problem is that there are two things
firstly these galaxies as you can see
they're relatively red right there's
quite a lot of light coming out in this
red part of the spectrum compared to
what's coming out in the blue part of
the spectrum and as I said they describe
it in the title it's a population of red
candidate massive galaxies so both of
these are the problem the reason why red
is a problem is because
the spectrum of a galaxy only becomes
red when it's no longer dominated by
those very young very blue very hot
Stars so when you see a red Galaxy
that's telling you that that Galaxy's
been around long enough for all those
very massive very blue stars to have
gone through their complete life cycle
blown up a supernovae gone away and that
sets a limit as to the age of the Galaxy
right a galaxy has to be in order to
have reached that stage of maturity it
has to be a few hundred million years
old at least
and that's getting a little
uncomfortable because here we are
identifying galaxies 600 million years
after the big bang
and yet they're already 200 million
years old so that means they have to
have been formed at the latest 400
million years after the big bang and so
that's pushing the formation of galaxies
back really quite close to the big bang
and the grand scheme of things you know
the universe now is what 13.8 billion
years old so a few hundred million years
after the big bang is really kind of
almost the blink of an eye somehow
you're making these galaxies and then
not only are they oldish because they're
red but they're actually massive when
you go through this process of
translating how much light there is
there into figuring out how much mass
there is you end up with these galaxies
being about sort of 10 to the 10 times
the mass of the Sun so 10 billion times
the mass of the sun which is a
respectable side Galaxy right there's a
sort of a tenth as as massive as a Milky
Way so not only do you have to make
these galaxies very close to the Big
Bang in relative terms but somehow you
have to make them very massive and since
the way we think Galaxy's form is by
sort of mass kind of accreting being
pulled together by gravity we expected
that galaxies would kind of build up
quite slowly that the first galaxies
that you're seeing would be quite low
mass ones and then over time they merge
with each other or they acquire more
material through gravity and they build
up to the kind of things that we see
today at a much slower rate so seeing
very massive quite old galaxies that
close to the Big Bang is really pushing
things really quite to the limit in
terms of our understanding of how
galaxies form I mean something could be
wrong yeah and the so there were two and
fundamentally there were two things that
could be wrong the observations could be
wrong or the theory could be wrong right
well the observations aren't wrong but I
guess it's the interpretation that the
observations could be wrong it could be
for whatever reason we really don't
understand these breaks the way we think
we did or somehow the way We're
translating the amount of light into the
amount of mass is wrong so there are
ways that the way we're interpreting the
observations could be wrong or it could
be that actually our understanding of
how Galaxy formation works and the
simulations we're doing of those early
stages of Galaxy formation just aren't
quite right and there's some extra bit
of physics that we haven't put in there
yet so you're right some some things you
know things are sufficiently intentioned
now that it's going to break and
something has to be wrong one of my
favorite things about Galactic astronomy
is how lovely galaxies look and the
images that come with it I always feel a
bit sad when I see you looking at all
the galaxies reduced to a graph yeah and
actually you know now we look at even
with the the power of the James Webb
Space Telescope we're looking at things
which are so far away if we just go back
to the picture of their picture they're
not very exciting are they really this
is why I study nearby galaxies right
because I like looking at those
beautiful spiral arms and all the other
Elegance of the nearby galaxies and
unfortunately even with jwst we're not
getting to that level of Beauty in these
distant things
well I want to talk about the physics
behind how you actually get a telescope
like this to point in the direction that
you want it to but as you squeeze Atomic
gas together you start turning it into
molecules start producing molecular
hydrogen as well so the reason why
astronomers are very interested in
molecular hydrogen is that that's
usually the density of material that
turns into Stars